so we were both on uh your episode of
the Mike Tyson hot boxing podcast yeah
what a [ __ ] show that was
why you say that I think that uh that
got Mike Tyson's co-host for that
episode like I don't think he's ever
even watched a single fight ever like a
man some questions that he had like
pre-prepared questions that were written
down that it just felt kind of awkward
that he was asking and then there was me
I was just on one dude yeah you you was
a he's an MMA Aficionado that was me
Steve he was he watches he watches the
prelims prelims yeah
I don't miss a fight but here's here's
why I was so not steered is that I got
the surgery to get the hardware out of
my collarbone the day before and like
I'm a clean and sober guy like I don't
uh do drugs and drink
for the last 14 years I've not been as
[ __ ] up on drugs as I just somehow got
off the general anesthesia from this oh
yeah
probably go back on my phone and find it
but after me surgery one time I'll never
forget put put on
doing this with me I'm putting the phone
there on video pressing video and going
I mean I'm just flopping what I mean I
don't remember being in bed it was when
I got this hand done actually because
I've had three wrist surgery he's two on
that one more on this one this was the
latest one
kind of lying in bed
um my the double bed I added my mom's
house was this when I was living in my
mum's was it was quite low to the floor
I remember just like rolling over and
you're staring dump
and being like what the [ __ ] was that
noise and I couldn't feel it but my hand
was on the floor not the general
understands what you can't feel nothing
in your arm my arm is just on the floor
just like what if I had to pick me up
and put it back in bed and roll over but
like you don't don't feel it for like it
wasn't it was like what you're
describing it's just like being able to
feel your arms you're talking about like
it [ __ ] flipped a switch on me that
need not be flipped like it just turned
me into a raving
[ __ ] out of control guy on drugs what
did they give you how about this that
was exactly my question what did they
give you then I gotta believe it was
just propofol standard issue general
anesthesia which have had time and time
again I've had so many yeah it wasn't
fast then it was there maybe they gave
me more like maybe something maybe I
just somehow reacted to it differently
but but uh for all my procedures that I
had general anesthesia it's never done
that to me and I just went kind of
Bonkers and I couldn't sleep and I was
on [ __ ] acting crazy all night and
then like I gotta go do this tattoo in
the morning I still hadn't [ __ ] slept
when I saw you at the Mike Tyson I still
had a slept and I was still frankly out
of my [ __ ] mind like uh yeah yeah you
didn't okay yeah that's what I was
saying to him I was like it's not it
wasn't I never didn't even look like he
doesn't slept oh well how about that I
think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what I've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out September 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because I'm proven dude New York Times
bestseller my first book's Five star
rated on Amazon and
it's one will be too so get the
autograph copy right now by pre-ordering
it at stevo.com
yeah dude